el invierno llegó a johnston pensilvania
y con él la tasa de contagio más alta
desde la aparición del virus en esta
clínica solidaria rosa lidón son con la
directora vigila constantemente el
avance de la pandemia en su ciudad
aquí en jones town con la crisis del 19
necesitamos que más gente se vacune
muchos han recibido la inyección pero
aún hay más gente que no la recibió cada
día leo el periódico y encuentro el
nombre de dos o tres personas de nuestro
condado que fallecieron por kobe 19
sin embargo en esta pequeña clínica de
johnston no falta nada para enfrentarse
al virus ni las dosis de vacuna ni los
médicos para administrarla
mezclo 18 mililitros de solución salina
con la vacuna y luego con cada frasco
para adultos puedo realizar 6 dosis de
vacuna
la doctora que eres una de nuestros
médicos es una voluntaria y es la más
antigua que
10 mil habitantes y menos del 40 por
ciento vacunados las causas la
impopularidad de la vacuna están
identificadas
piensan que otras cosas funcionan mejor
que la vacuna como la hidroxi cloroquina
dicen que la vacuna no fue
suficientemente probada y todo tipo de
cosas así este mientras empieza un nuevo
año marcado por el cob y 19 en los bares
de johnston 6 consumidores de cada 10
todavía no están vacunados